Well, you guys know we love Airbnb. I also just did a ladies' birthday trip. It was my friend's 50th birthday. All of us gals drove up the coast. It was so fun. We had the kitchen to hang out in, but then we all had our own space because, you know, we love each other. But I mean, I kind of want my own space at night. You know what I'm saying. We love the privacy. They're always in such great locations where you can really get to know the town you're in. And there's some real hidden gyms out there. These little pockets and neighbors, that you might not see if you stayed at a hotel. Listen, I could go on and on about Airbnb because I love it. It's a great way to travel with friends and family. And you know, your home might be perfect for Airbnb. If you frequently travel or have extra space, maybe you go out of town at the same time every year for a family trip, your home could earn you money while you're away. Your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at Airbnb.ca.ca. slash host. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends.
好吧，你们都知道我们爱Airbnb。我最近还去了一趟女士生日之旅。那是为我朋友庆祝50岁生日。我们一帮姐妹沿着海岸驱车北上。太好玩了。我们有厨房可以聚在一起，但同时我们都有各自的空间，因为，你知道的，我们彼此相爱。但我的意思是，到了晚上我还是想要自己的空间。你们懂我的意思。我们喜欢隐私。它们总是位于非常棒的位置，让你能真正了解你所在的城镇。那里有一些真正的隐藏宝地。这些小地方和街区，如果你住在酒店里可能根本看不到。听着，关于Airbnb我可以滔滔不绝，因为我太爱它了。这是和亲朋好友一起旅行的绝佳方式。而且你知道的，你的家可能非常适合放在Airbnb上出租。如果你经常旅行或有额外空间，也许你每年都会在同一时间出城进行家庭旅行，那么在你不在的时候，你的家就能为你赚钱。你的家可能比你想象的更值钱。登录 Airbnb.ca/host 了解具体价值。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。
And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Howdy? How's it going? Pretty good. How are you? I mean, I'm good. I've started a new TikTok trend.
现在我们专门为你带来终极的办公室爱好者播客。每周我们都会通过独家采访、幕后细节和许多闺蜜故事，带你更深入地探索《办公室》的世界。我们是“办公室辣妈 6.0”。你好。嗨，最近怎么样？挺好的，你呢？我挺好的。我掀起了一个新的TikTok潮流。
What? A TikTok trend, I started doing a thing that I saw. You want to know what it is? Yeah, I'm not on TikTok. Well, me either, but it made its way over to Instagram, which is how I found out about it. Is this something you can show me right now here? It's something you can do every morning, and it's supposed to boost your health and metabolism and stuff. Here's what it is. Okay. You jump up and down 50 times first thing in the morning. It takes less than a minute. So it's this new trend.
什么？TikTok潮流，我开始模仿我看到的一个东西。你想知道是什么吗？想啊，我没玩TikTok。好吧，我也没有，但它传到了Instagram上，我就是这么知道的。这是你现在就能在这里展示给我的东西吗？这是你每天早上都可以做的事情，据说它可以促进健康、新陈代谢之类的一起。它是这样的。好吧。大清早上下跳跃50次。只需要不到一分钟。所以这就是这个新潮流。
Why? I'll have to pee if I jump up and down. You pee first lady. You don't have to do it immediately after getting out of bed. You can pee, you can shower, and then jump up and down 50 times. It's just like some time in your morning. Okay, okay. You've got to jump up and down.
为什么？我要是上下跳的话会想尿尿的。先去尿尿，女士。你不需要一醒来就立刻做。你可以先上厕所，洗个澡，然后再上下跳50次。就安排在早上某个时间段就行。好吧，好吧。你得上下跳。
How high do I have to jump? Not high. Just jump. But here's the thing. I started it. I'm on like day maybe six. after the first day my calves were so sore. Just one day of 50 jumps, my calves, I felt it.
我得跳多高？不用跳多高。跳起来就行。但重点是。我开始了。我大概进行到第六天了。第一天过后我的小腿酸得不行。就跳了50次的那么一天，我的小腿，我真的有感觉。
When's the last time you jumped on a trampoline? Because I jumped on the trampoline with my kids a while back, and I felt like I'd been in a car accident after. It's been a long time. But supposedly this helps to, like, get your circulation going and flush your lymphatic system. And I don't know, the lady in the Instagram video had great things to say after doing it for one month.
你上次在蹦床上跳是什么时候？因为我前段时间跟孩子们一起在蹦床上跳，之后我感觉自己就像出了车祸一样。那是好久以前的事了。但据说这有助于促进血液循环，还能冲刷淋巴系统。我不知道，Instagram视频里的那位女士在坚持了一个月之后，给出了非常高的评价。
And I got totally, I was like, I'll do it. So I'll keep everyone posted. Well, you know what I started doing. I think I know this. I saw a video where a lady pats herself down. She starts at her shoulder and she goes pat, pat, pat, pat, pat, pat, pat. All the way down her arm. Pat, pat, pat, pat.
我完全被说服了，我想：我也要试。所以我会随时向大家汇报进展的。好吧，你知道我开始做什么了吗？我想我知道。我看到一个视频，里面有个女士在拍打自己的身体。她从肩膀开始，然后啪、啪、啪、啪、啪、啪、啪地一直拍打。顺着整条胳膊往下拍。啪、啪、啪、啪。
And then she does her legs. That's a lymphatic thing too. Well, I started doing it and it does wake you up. Oh, so you are slapping yourself awake and I'm jumping myself away. There it is. Same world. Okay. No.
然后她拍打腿部。那也是排淋巴的动作。好吧，我也开始这样做了，这确实能让你清醒过来。哦，所以你是把自己拍醒的，而我是把自己跳醒的。就是这样。殊途同归。好吧。没有。
All right. Well, listen, everybody, we've got a really fun episode today. we are kicking things off with a big announcement. We talked about this a little bit in our second drink this week, but in case you didn't hear, the paper is now airing on NBC every Monday at 8.30 p.m. Eastern 7.30 p.m. Central. Bing, bing, boom. Did I do it?
好吧，听着，各位，我们今天有一集非常有趣的节目。我们要以一个重大宣布来拉开序幕。我们在本周的第二杯饮品里稍微聊过这个，但如果你还没听说，《办公室》现在每周一晚上8:30（东部时间）/7:30（中部时间）在NBC播出。叮，叮，轰。我学得像吗？
Nine. Ding ding ding on ding. Remember the little peacock? Dun, down, down. Well, it started this week, and we're super excited about it. Yes, it's being bundled with St. Dennis Medical, which, as you know, stars Wendy MacLendon Covey, aka Concierge Marie. St. Dennis Medical was created by Office alum Justin Spitzer, so basically Monday nights on NBC, you get two great comedies from office folks. I love it. And guys, guess what
九。丁丁丁咚。还记得那个小孔雀吗？咚，咚，咚。好吧，本周已经开播了，我们对此感到超级兴奋。是的，它和《圣丹尼斯医疗》捆绑播出，如你所知，该剧由温迪·麦克伦登·科维主演，也就是大家熟悉的“礼宾员玛丽”。《圣丹尼斯医疗》是由《办公室》老员工贾斯汀·斯皮策创作的，所以基本上在NBC的周一晚上，你能看到两部来自《办公室》团队的精彩喜剧。我太喜欢了。大家猜怎么着？
else? We are here to announce to you all that starting the new year, we're going to break down all of the paper episodes. So get caught up on Peacock or NBC and meet us back here in the new year for all the insider info and tidbits and trivia. We're going to be hitting everyone up. Mm-hmm. And we also just put some folders up on the Office Ladies' website where you can submit questions for each of the paper episodes. But we're not done with fun stuff. Today, we've got a fun crossover episode for you. Jenna and I are going to be joined by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas, the host of How We Made Your Mother, the rewatch podcast. That is so fantastic. Yes. If you are a loyal listener of Office Ladies, you already know that this show,
还有什么？我们在这里向大家宣布，从新年开始，我们将逐集剖析《办公室》的所有剧集。所以请在Peacock或NBC上补看，然后在新年回到这里，和我们一起探讨所有的内部消息、花絮和冷知识。我们会联系每一个人的。嗯嗯。而且我们刚刚还在“办公室辣妈”的网站上设置了一些文件夹，你可以在那里为《办公室》的每一集提交问题。但有趣的还没结束呢。今天，我们为你准备了一集有趣的联动节目。我和珍娜将迎来乔希·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯，也就是重温播客《我们是如何认识你母亲的》的主持人。这太棒了。是的。如果你是《办公室辣妈》的忠实听众，你一定已经知道了这个节目，
How We Made Your Mother, is now available on the Office Ladies Network. And for those of you not familiar with How We Made Your Mother, it is a great rewatch podcast of the hit show How I Met Your Mother, which ran on CBS for nine seasons from 2005 to 2014. The show was a huge hit. It was nominated for something like 28 Emmy Awards, including Best Comedy Series. Josh Radner played the character Ted Mosby. I love it because he says he is the I and how I met your mother. And Craig Thomas was the co-creator of the show. And it's so cool to hear their behind-the-scenes stories from their different perspectives.
《我们是如何认识你母亲的》现在已经在“办公室辣妈”网络上线了。对于那些对《How We Made Your Mother》不太熟悉的人来说，这是一档非常棒的重温播客，回顾了2005年至2014年在CBS播出了九季的热门剧集《老爸老妈的浪漫史》。这部剧当年大受欢迎。它获得了大约28项艾美奖提名，包括最佳喜剧剧集。乔希·拉德纳饰演了泰德·莫斯比这个角色。我太喜欢了，因为他说他就是《老爸老妈的浪漫史》里的那个“我”。而克雷格·托马斯是该剧的联合创作者。听到他们从各自不同的视角分享幕后故事，真的太酷了。
Yeah, I mean, I watched the show when it was on. I loved it. And their podcast is so great. They have that unique perspective of having both an actor and a co-co. creator. So I feel like it's like if Greg Daniels sat in on every episode of Office Ladies and told us what the writers were thinking when they crafted the storylines. But also, Josh and Craig, they're just such thoughtful, positive people. Like, their energy is so uplifting. I just, I love listening to them. Me too. I was telling my Josh, because now my Josh is also listening and
对啊，我的意思是，这部剧播出时我就看了。我超级喜欢。他们的播客也太棒了。他们拥有独特的视角，因为同时拥有演员和联合创作者。所以我觉得这就像是格雷格·丹尼尔斯坐在《办公室尼》的每一集录制现场，告诉我们编剧在构思剧情时的真实想法。而且，乔希和克雷格，他们真的是那种非常有思想、充满正能量的人。他们的活力超级鼓舞人心。我就是、我就是喜欢听他们说话。我也是。我跟我家的乔希说——因为现在我家的乔希也在听，而且
loves it. I said, aren't they just so easy and pleasant? It's like they're wonderful to hang out with, You know? Okay, so everyone here is what's happening today. Craig and Josh watched an episode of the office and they're going to be our guests on office ladies. That's right. We watch Season 5 Customer Survey. Now, me and Angie, we watched the Peacock Superfan version. Craig and Josh watched the original broadcast version. You might remember, this is the episode where Pam is away at art school in New York and she and Jim spend the day listening to one another's day over of those little teeny tiny bluths. Meanwhile, Angela and Andy are trying to plan their wedding, and this is the episode where they decide to get married at Shrewt Farms. Yeah. This is also the
超级喜欢。我说，他们是不是特别随和、特别讨人喜欢？就感觉和他们在一起相处会非常开心，你知道吗？好了，各位，今天的节目安排是这样的。克雷格和乔希看了一集《办公室》，他们将作为我们的嘉宾做客“办公室辣妈”。没错。我们看的是第五季的《客户调查》。我和安吉看了Peacock超级粉丝版。克雷格和乔希看的是原版广播播出血。你可能还记得，这一集里潘去了纽约的艺术学校，她和吉姆通过那些微小的蓝牙耳机听着彼此度过的一整天。与此同时，安吉拉和安迪正试图筹备他们的婚礼，这一集里他们决定在施鲁特农场结婚。是的。这也是
episode where Dwight and Jim both get really horrible feedback on their customer reviews, and they figure out that Kelly purposely doctored the reviews as a revenge because they didn't go to her America's Got Talent Party. This is one of my favorite episodes. I'm so excited to hear their take on it. I loved re-watching it. And you guys, not only that, tomorrow, we're going to be on how we made your mother chatting with them about an episode on their show. So be sure to check that out as well. Well, let's take a break and then we'll get into it. I want you to take a second and become aware of the smell around you. Does it like, kind of like nothing? Do you smell something? Scent has this amazing power to influence the
这一集里，德怀特和吉姆在客户评价中都得到了非常糟糕的反馈，他们发现原来是凯莉为了报复他们没有去她的《美国达人秀》派对而故意篡改了评价。这是我最喜欢的剧集之一。我很高兴听到他们对此的看法。重新看这一集真的太棒了。而且各位，不仅如此，明天，我们将做客《我们是如何认识你母亲的》，与他们畅聊他们剧中的一集。所以一定要去收听那一集哦。好了，我们先休息一下，然后就开始正题。我想让你花几秒钟感受一下你周围的气味。是不是有点像，闻起来什么也没有？你闻到什么气味了吗？气味有一种神奇的力量，能够影响
energy of a space or express the individuality of a space. It can enhance your mood and your feelings. And Pura wants to tap into that positivity of scent. Pura makes the coolest diffusers, mini diffusers, larger diffusers, and they have a gazillion scents available. So if you want to walk into your bathroom and have it smell like a tropical vacation, you can have that. If you want to walk into your kitchen and have it smell like the holidays or like fresh baked cookies. And right now, Pura is having a special promo where you get a free Pura set when you subscribe. Subscribe to a festive scent now and easily swap it later. This exclusive deal won't last, so shop now at pura.com. The holidays are here, and that means it's the most wonderful time of the year to save
一个空间的能量，或者表达一个空间的个性。它可以提升你的情绪和感受。而Pura想要利用气味带来的这种积极能量。Pura制造了最酷炫的扩香器，迷你扩香器、大型扩香器，他们有成千上万种气味可供选择。所以如果你想走进浴室，让它闻起来像热带度假胜地，你完全可以做到。如果你想走进厨房，让它闻起来像节日或者刚出炉的饼干。现在，Pura正在进行一项特别促销活动，订阅即可免费获得一套Pura套装。现在就订阅节日香氛，以后还可以轻松更换。这个独家优惠不会持续太久，快去 pura.com 抢购吧。假期到了，这意味着这是利用
with racketon. Use racketon to stack cashback at your favorite stores on top of holiday sales. That's savings on savings. With racketon, you can get cash back on gifts for everyone on your list, from toys for the kids to kitchen gear, for the person who loves to cook. to electronics for everyone. You can even save on something for yourself. Just shop the stores you love and cashback is automatically added to your account and you can choose to get paid via Interact E-Transfer, PayPal, or check. Join for free today and get a new member bonus after minimum qualifying purchases.
Rakuten省钱的绝佳时机。使用Rakuten在您喜爱的商店里叠加返现和假期促销优惠。这就是省上加省。使用Rakuten，您可以为清单上的每个人采购礼物赚取返现，从孩子们的玩具到厨房用具，送给热爱烹饪的人；再到送给每个人的电子产品。你甚至可以省下钱给自己买点东西。只需在您喜爱的商店购物，返现就会自动计入您的账户，您可以选择通过Interact电子转账、PayPal或支票领取现金。今天免费加入，并在完成最低达标购买后获得新会员奖金。
Just go to rackettin.ca. Download the app or install the browser extension. That's R-A-K-U-T-E-N. Terms and conditions apply. Hi. Hello. Hello, guys. Hi, Josh Radner and Craig Thomas. Welcome to office ladies.
只需访问 rackettin.ca。下载应用程序或安装浏览器扩展程序。网址是 R-A-K-U-T-E-N。适用条款和条件。嗨。你好。你们好。嗨，乔希·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯。欢迎来到办公室辣妈。
I didn't know those to us or to your audience, but hello. This is so exciting. Guys, thanks for having us. And every sense of that word. Yeah, this is the first time. We're all like, I guess in one space together, like seeing each other. Yeah, this is it. I'm meeting you.
我不知道这是对我们说的还是对你们的听众说的，但大家好。太让人兴奋了。伙计们，谢谢你们邀请我们。在每一个意义上都是如此。对啊，这是第一次。我们所有人都在想，好像终于在一个空间里聚在一起，面对面地见面了。是的，就是这样。我终于见到你了。
We are so excited, guys. so excited to have you on Office Ladies Network. We love your podcast. Yes. You guys are the best of this. I mean so much coming from you. Thank you guys for having us. We're thrilled to be joining forces with you. You guys, you're the best at this. It's an honor. Our audience is going to love your podcast. You're doing such a great job. Jen and I've been talking so much about the two different perspectives that you bring to the rewatch. It's so good. Oh, thank you guys. Well, we're friends in real life, like you guys are. That part helps. That's so funny you think that, Craig, but go on. Sorry. No, wait. Yeah, yeah. No, that's sweet. Wait a second. Well, we love you and how
我们太兴奋了，伙计们。非常高兴你们能加入“办公室辣妈”网络。我们太喜欢你们的播客了。是的。你们才是这方面的专家。听到你们这么说真是受宠若惊。谢谢你们邀请我们。我们非常高兴能与你们强强联手。你们才是最棒的。这真是莫大的荣幸。我们的听众一定会喜欢你们的播客。你们做得太棒了。珍娜和我一直在讨论你们为重播节目带来的两种不同视角。真的太棒了。哦，谢谢你们。嗯，我们在现实生活中也是朋友，就像你们一样。这一点很有帮助。克雷格，你这么想太搞笑了，不过你继续说。抱歉。不，等等。对，对，对。不，这太贴心了。等一下。好吧，我们很喜欢你们以及你们
you break down your episodes, and we thought it would be fun to have you on to talk about an episode of the office. So we asked you guys to watch customer survey from season five. Yes, we love this episode, and we were curious. What was your overall reaction to it? was positive. That's good. I had a positive reaction. Good. I watched it twice.
剖析剧集的方式，所以我们觉得邀请你们来聊聊《办公室》的一集会很有趣。因此我们让你们看了第五季的《客户调查》。是的，我们非常喜欢这一集，我们也很好奇。你们对它的整体反应是怎样的？非常正面。那就好。我的反应很正面。很好。我看了两遍。
I really, first to kind of let it wash over me, and the second time I just wanted to jot down things that delighted me, which is something Craig and I do on our own podcast. But I don't know. One thing I was really struck with is like there's every character is like there's no kind of heroically virtuous character on the show. Like, everyone's got their spiky edges, and everyone can be a little ethically compromised. But also, there's this, it's not just, Michael's the most overt kind of like me, like me, like me, like me.
第一遍我只是让它自然地流淌，第二遍我只想记下那些让我感到愉悦的事情，这也是我和克雷格在我们自己的播客里会做的事。不过我不知道。让我印象深刻的一点是，剧中的每一个角色——里面没有那种英雄般品德高尚的角色。每个人都有点刺儿，每个人都可能在道德上有那么点小瑕疵。而且，不仅是迈克尔那种最直白的“关注我、关注我、关注我”的渴望，
But everyone is obsessed on some level with their perception, like how they're being perceived, especially in this episode, because it's literally about feedback. Like, what are people thinking of me? And even Jim's thing at the end, like, I didn't, I wasn't invited. You know what I mean? Like, I didn't get a mug, right? Like, yeah, there's something very human about, um, is, uh, I mean, it's like, it's Mindy's book. Is everyone hanging out without me?
而是每个人在某种程度上都痴迷于自己的形象，也就是别人是如何看待自己的，尤其是这一集，因为这字面意思上就是关于反馈的。大家是怎么看我的？甚至连吉姆最后的那场戏，就像是，我没有被邀请。你知道我的意思吗？就是我没有得到一个马克杯，对吧？就像是，是的，这种感觉非常人性化，关于——呃，这就像明迪的书里写的那样，大家是不是在背着我聚会？
Yeah. That's very human. And, uh, one other thing, I had heard this thing that all television is about family at some core level. Um, I think it's because that's how families would gather around and watch, you know, watch a story together. But the office is a family. You know, it's not a vertical family.
对。这非常人性化。还有一件事，我曾经听说过一种说法，即所有电视剧的核心都在某种程度上关乎家庭。嗯，我想这是因为这是家庭聚集在一起观看、共同体验一个故事的方式。但《办公室》就是一个家庭。你知道的，它不是一个纵向的家庭。
It's not like, you know, genetic family, but it's a horizontal. family. Same with how I met your mother. It's a chosen family. So I think both shows, our family shows, and you see, especially in this episode, like, the way the characters in the office fight, it's very sibling-like. Very, yeah, they're really, they're at each other's throats in a very familial way. What about you, Craig? I just found, I loved it. This is a great episode. I hadn't seen this since it aired. I'm struck by how there's so many similarities to how I'm at your mother. There's so many, as a writer, like, and a showrunner, like, this has so many of the things I'm looking for.
它不是那种基因上的家庭，而是一个横向的家庭。这跟《老爸老妈的浪漫史》一样。这是一个自选的家庭。所以我认为这两部剧，都是家庭剧，你会看到，尤其是在这一集里，办公室里的角色们吵架的方式，非常像兄弟姐妹。非常像，对，他们以一种非常像家人的方式针锋相对。克雷格，你觉得呢？我发现，我太喜欢了。这是一集伟大的剧集。自从它播出以来我就没看过。让我震惊的是，它和《老爸老妈的浪漫史》有如此多的相似之处。作为一名编剧兼剧集运作人，有太多太多我一直在寻找的东西。
Setups and payoffs. These stealthy little things, these little seeds that you plant, you don't even know it's important to the story. And then at the end, it kind of gut punches you with how important it is. Those little, like, Bluetooth things. Josh and I talk a lot about how technology has caught up with and surpassed us, you know, our TV shows in the last 20 years where it's like, these incredibly little ear things are, it's like people have this now.
设置与回报。这些隐秘的小细节，这些你甚至不知道对故事很重要的草蛇灰线。然后在最后，它给你重重一击，让你意识到它有多么重要。那些小东西，比如那些蓝牙耳机。我和乔希经常讨论，在过去20年里，科技是如何赶上甚至超越了我们的电视节目的，就像是，这些不可思议的小耳朵设备，现在人们真的都有了。
But like at the time, that was, that's always hilarious to me when technology sort of comes around but like we call it old tech i know it's like we have a lot of old tech put it that way on how i met your mother but just the idea that that becomes really heartbreaking at the end or really like this real challenge to jim and pam's relationship all born out of what seems like this light little comedic runner about the things in their ears and they're hearing each other's sides of the conversation the fact that that had this emotional punch at the end was so clever we also talk about on how i met your mother the whole series of how i met her mother is a mystery right who's the mother. How does he meet her? What happens? It's this larger series. We discovered that kind of a lot of
但在当时，每当科技以某种方式卷土重来——但我们称之为老旧科技——我总是觉得这太搞笑了。我知道，就像我们在《老爸老妈的浪漫史》里有很多老旧科技一样，但仅仅是这个点在最后变得非常令人心碎，或者说真正成为对吉姆和潘关系的巨大挑战，这一切都源于一个看似轻松的小喜剧支线——也就是他们耳朵里的东西，他们听到了彼此对话的另一端——事实证明它在最后具有如此强大的情感冲击力，真是太聪明了。我们在《老爸老妈的浪漫史》中也讨论过，整个《老爸老妈的浪漫史》系列其实是一个谜题，对吧？谁是妈妈？他是怎么遇到她的？发生了什么？这是一个更大的系列。我们发现，《老爸老妈的浪漫史》中许多优秀的剧集，微缩起来其实都是悬疑剧。我真的很喜欢这里面好像有什么阴谋的设定。这是一个福尔摩斯式的案件。这些客户调查表有点不对劲。一开始，你以为他们只是因为自尊心受挫，所以在胡思乱想觉得有什么不对劲吗？不，其实真的有什么不对劲。这里确实发生了某种邪恶的事情。而他们开始破解这个谜案，以及明迪的角色真的做了手脚并进行了破坏——这居然是真的。我太喜欢这个了。
the good episodes of how much mother in miniature are mysteries. And I really like the idea that there's something afoot here. There's a Sherlock Holmes case. Something's weird about these customer surveys. At first, do you think they're just like their egos are bruised and they're making it up that there's something weird? No, there actually is something weird. Like there is something nefarious that is happening here. And the idea that they start to solve this mystery case and that she, that like, Mendeu's character really did, like, tamper and sabotage. Like, it actually is true. I loved that.
我喜欢这一集的主线是一个正在被解开的谜团。我喜欢这一集以一个巨大的悬念结束：这对吉姆和潘意味着什么？是的，还有迈克尔，以及那个温馨的镜头——迈克尔假装训斥她交了错误的文件和调查表，迈克尔展现出脆弱的一面真的很感人，他说：“从来没有人去我的派对。我做了那么多的鳄梨酱。为什么我要做这么多鳄梨酱？”
I love that the through line of the episode is a mystery being solved. I love that the episode ends on a big cliffhanger of, like, what does this mean for Jim and Pam? Yeah, and Michael and, like, the bonding scene where Michael pretends to scold her for having, you know, given the erroneous and files surveys, is really sweet that Michael gets this vulnerable moment to say, no one ever comes to my parties either. I make so much guacamole. Why do I make so much guacamole?
这是整集中我最喜欢的台词。这也是另一回事。当一个情节既非常非常搞笑，同时又拥有如此惊人的情感深度和悲剧色彩，而且极其人性化。我认为这就是这两部剧的共通之处。对。你知道另一个共通之处吗。两部剧的片头曲都是绝对的神曲。
That's my favorite line in the whole episode. And that's the other thing. It's when something's really, really funny and yet has this incredible emotional depth and pathos to it and it's really human. And I think that's the overlap between these two shows. Yeah. You know another overlap. Both have opening credits with songs that are bangers.
啊。是的，你说得对。就像《办公室》的主题曲一响起来的时候，还有《老爸老妈的浪漫史》也是，就觉得，好吧，好吧——你心里就有数了。它能让你兴奋起来。那是卡特和我的乐队。那是我和卡特。那是我们的乐队，《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的主题曲就是《The Solids》乐队唱的。对，就是我们。卡特和我在大学里一起组乐队时认识的。在我们一起写电视剧剧本之前，我们就已经一起写歌了。我们的乐队The Solids创作了这首主题曲。乔希，我感到非常荣幸，能和《办公室》的主题曲相提并论，我认为那绝对是一首神曲。而且我有好一阵子没听过了，
Ah. Yes, you're right. Like when the office theme song, when it kicks up and the same with how I made your mother, it's like, okay, okay, like you kind of know. It gets you psyched. Yeah. That's Carter in my band. That's me and Carter. That's our band, the How I Met Your Mother theme song, The Solid. Yeah, that's us. Carter and I met in college playing in bands together. We were writing songs together before we were writing TV together. And we did our band, The Solid's did the theme song. I'm very honored, Josh, to be mentioned in the breath as the office theme song, which I think is a total banger. And I had not heard it in a minute
因为我有一段时间没重温了。我写下的一条笔记是：“天哪，这首主题曲太炸了。”这首主题曲真的能让你超级兴奋。确实如此。两部都是。每次听到它们我都觉得很开心。我就想，好吧。对。真的。确实如此。我觉得两部剧我最喜欢的点之一，就是那种救赎时刻——当某个角色在苦苦挣扎时，总会有那么一刻，你的内心会发生转变。我觉得你们把这一点处理得非常好。我超爱那个时刻。这一集中我最喜欢的时刻之一，就是迈克尔和凯莉之间的那场戏，当时他分享了自己有多么痛苦。
because I hadn't rewatched in a while. I wrote down one of my notes was, God, this theme song kicks ass. It just gets you so excited that theme song. It's true. Both of them. Every time I hear them, I get happy. I'm like, okay. Yeah. Yeah. So true. It does. I think one of the things I like about both of the shows is that that redemption moment where there is a character that is struggling with something and there's always that moment where your heart takes a turn. And I thought you guys did that so well. And I love the moment. One of my favorite moments in this episode is between Michael and Kelly and when he shares how much
他对她坦诚相待，这与他平时的镜头前表演完全不同，乔希，他平时那种像是渴望获得关注的角色，但在那一刻他对她真的非常真诚。我一直很喜欢迈克尔身上这种转变的时刻。
he struggles. And he gets really honest with her in a way that's not performative for the camera, the way he normally is, Josh. He is kind of like the pick-me like character, but he was just really honest with her. And I used to love that transition moment for Michael.
是的。这也让我想到——人们可能会问自己的一个问题是：为什么这个电影摄制组还在拍这些人？是的。但我的看法是——
Yeah. You know, it also occurs to me like a question one might ask themselves is like, why is this film crew still filming these people. Yes. But the way I think about it is like,
一个拥有极佳电影制作眼光的人会觉得：这些人太迷人了。这里面有一个迷人的故事在上演。它不是关于国王和王后的，也不是关于超级富豪的。它是关于普通人的。多年来，吉姆和潘之间有一些时刻，就像——
like a person with a really good filmmaking eye would be like, these are fascinating people. Like there's a fascinating story going on here. And it's not about kings and queens and it's not about super wealthy people. It's about people. And there were moments, you know, with Jim and Pam over the years that were like, like, Chekhov.
契诃夫的作品一样。就像你知道的，在简·奥斯汀的小说里什么的，指尖轻轻擦过，然后就像魔法一样，像一朵巨大的烟花在绽放——我觉得正是这种克制，赋予了它那种神话般的品质，如果这样说得通的话——它真的只是关于斯克兰顿的普通人。如果你看过的话——这就是为什么在某些方面，我甚至比普通电影更喜欢纪录片，因为看着人们在毫无防备的状态下表现自己。就像你在机场或杂货店里观察人们一样，每个人都是出色的演员。每个人都在——每个人都在精湛地表演如何挑选一个甜瓜。
Like they're like, you know, like a you know in the Jane Austen or something like the fingertips graze together and it's just like magic like big firework kind of thing and I feel like the modesty of it is actually what gives it its mythic quality if that makes sense like that it's just really about people in Scranton and if you ever watch um that's why I think I in some ways I love documentaries even more than regular films because watching people behave in in a unselfconscious way Like, if you watch people in the airport or in the grocery store, everyone is a brilliant actor. Like, everyone is a, everyone is giving like a brilliant performance of picking out a melon.
你知道的，他们就在那里装模作样地挑。观察他们太迷人了。我戏剧项目的负责人曾说：“我从来不会感到无聊，因为周围到处都是人。我可以只去研究人类行为，你知道的。”是的。那是我在机场最喜欢的事情。我会带一本日志，然后把人们在做的事情随手记下来。
You know, they're like, it's actually doing it. And it's fascinating to watch. The woman who ran my drama program was like, I'm never bored because there are people around. Like, I can just study human behavior, you know. Yeah. That's my favorite thing at an airport. I take a journal and I will just. write down what people are doing.
确实如此。我太喜欢了。不过，我也觉得我们在跟那个把我们从现实中拉开的、令人分心的长方形屏幕做斗争。是的。没错。顺便说一句，安吉拉，那看起来非常可疑。我只是想提前提醒你，你可能会在某个时候在机场被捕。
Yeah. And it's true. I love it. Well, I also think we're fighting the distracting rectangle that is taking us away from that. Yeah. Yeah, for sure. By the way, Angela, that looks very suspicious. I just want to be prepared that you may get arrested at an airport at some point.
如果你只是拿着一个本子在做笔记。小心点就行了。我只想说这些。每个收听“办公室辣妈”的人都知道我一直写日记。我在我们的播客里读过。所以我希望当我像这样在机场观察别人并随手记下东西时，某个“办公室辣妈”的成员会来帮我、来拯救我。如果有人说：“把她抓起来，她在搞鬼。”
If you're just taking, if you just have a pad out, you're taking notes. Just be careful. That's all I'm saying. Everyone that listens to Office Ladies knows that I keep a journal. I have read it on our podcast. So I hope that when I am, like, observing people at the airport and jotting things down, some office ladies member will come to my, will come to my aid. If someone's like, write her up, she's up to shenanigans.
她怎么没在玩手机。对啊。她为什么不玩手机？我刚读完一本书叫《告诉我一切》，我真的超级喜欢。这本书的主题是：每个人的生活都有一个值得讲述的故事。所以它是缅因州一个小镇上许多不同的人的生活小片段的集合。我简直爱不释手，因为它就像是书本形式的“观察人类”。
She's not on her phone. Yeah. Why is she not on her phone? I just read this book called Tell Me Everything that I just absolutely loved. And the theme of this book is that every person's life has a story worth telling. And so it's a collection of small. snippets of a whole bunch of different people's lives from this town in Maine. And I just, like, couldn't get enough of it because it was, like, people watching in book form.
但这给了我一个灵感。我要跟你们分享一下。我觉得我做不到。克雷格，根据你刚才对安吉拉说的话，我突然有了这个想法。这太疯狂了，不过。这真的太疯狂了。我听起来可能会像个疯子。我想的是：我能不能——我得在一个城市里这么做。你在开车的情况下可不能这么做。但是，我能不能——
But it gave me an idea. I'm going to run it by you guys. I think I can't do it. Sort of Craig, based on what you just told, Angela, I had this idea. This is so insane, though. This is so insane. I'm going to sound so crazy. I was like, could I, like, I'd have to do this in a city. You can't do this in a driving situation. But, like, could I? secretly follow a person all day. Stop, we're going to stop you right there. And just observe all of what they do. Like, what did they buy at the store?
秘密跟踪一个人一整天？等等，我们得在这里打断你。然后观察他们所做的一切。比如他们在商店里买了什么？
Like maybe I start, you know, like, what are they? Oh, I wonder what they're going to cook. Television and films, Jenna Fisher. Oh, my gosh. And it was all, the plan was all captured on the podcast. Yeah, she confessed before she even did it. I can't. I can't. It just, it just, I am similar.
也许我开始，你知道的，比如——他们要煮什么？影视剧啊，珍娜·费舍尔。哦，天哪。而且整个计划都被播客录下来了。对，她在动手之前就先自首了。我做不到。我做不到。只是，只是——我和他们很像，
like we're talking about, I am fascinated by the details of people. Well, I mean, that's one of the great things about the office. Like Josh was saying, you feel like you're sneaking in. Josh, I was so struck. I said many similarities between our two shows and that I love and I could say more. The fact that this ends on kind of like a couple of cliffhangers, Angela, the you and the you and Dwight scene at the end, we have to talk about that scene. That was magnificent.
就像我们讨论的那样，我对外表之下的细节着迷。好吧，我的意思是，《办公室》伟大的地方之一就在于此。就像乔希说的，你感觉自己像是潜入了进去。乔希，我太震撼了。我说过我们的两部剧有很多相似之处，我都非常喜欢，而且我还能说出更多。事实上，这一集以几个悬念结束——安吉拉，最后你和德怀特的对手戏，我们得聊聊那场戏。那太精彩了。
We got to get there at some point. Oh, it's so weird. One thing that's very, very different about our two shows is we used music to be very very emotionally manipulative to the audience. We were, we were music nerds. Like I said, Carter and I, like we are, our connection was musical before it was writing words on a page. Josh, it would, Josh is a complete music nerd and would come and pitch us songs that we'd put on the show. I was really struck watching it again, watching the office for the first time in a few years, the quietness, the fact that there's no music, the fact that the soundtrack
我们总得聊到那里的。哦，太诡异了。我们的两部剧有一个非常非常不同的地方，那就是我们用音乐来对观众进行非常非常情绪化的操控。我们是——我们是不折不扣的音乐迷。就像我说的，卡特和我，我们的联系在把文字写在纸上之前就已经在音乐上建立起来了。乔希，乔希是一个彻头彻尾的音乐迷，他会来向我们推荐我们可以用在剧中的歌曲。我再次观看时真的很震惊，这是我几年来第一次重温《办公室》，那种安静感——没有背景音乐，音轨里只有办公室的声音，
is the sounds of an office, it's breathing, it's papers moving, it's keyboards clacking. There's something so hypnotic, wonderfully hypnotic, that really draws you in. You really, it really is voyeuristic. You really are there just spying on people. And it just works so profoundly well to make you, you're in those characters' shoes, and you're not being told how to feel. You're just there. I heard about this thing that's taking off in Scandinavia, and it's called Slow TV. Have you guys heard about this? It's basically like long, uninterrupted scenes, scenes where people are in nature. There's a story being told, but it's like scenes in nature that are just allowed to I think like as things get so fast paced, people are longing for just like slow it down, like
那是呼吸声、纸张翻动的声音、键盘敲击声。有一种非常催眠、奇妙的催眠感，真正把你吸引了进去。你真的有一种偷窥的感觉。你真的就只是在那里监视别人。这种效果非常深刻地发挥了作用，让你身临其境，进入那些角色的鞋子里，而且没有人告诉你该怎么去感受。你就在那里。我听说过一件在斯堪的纳维亚半岛兴起的事情，叫做“慢电视”。你们听说过吗？基本上就是漫长、不间断的镜头，人们在大自然中的镜头。里面有一个故事在讲述，但就像是大自然中的镜头，任由其——我觉得随着节奏变得越来越快，人们渴望慢下来，比如放慢我的节奏，放慢这个故事的节奏，给我一点喘息的时间。有时我在手机上花太多时间后，也会有这种感觉：天哪，把这东西拿开，让我——我不知道，给我讲个更长一点的故事什么的。我可以借用刚才珍娜关于跟踪人的犯罪计划说一件事吗？跟踪某人一天，是的，请说。你们听说过一个东西吗，我想它叫《晦涩悲伤词典》？这是一本非常适合作为礼物的书，如果你想送礼物给别人或自己。但这个家伙发明了新词。
slow me down, slow this story down, give me a moment to breathe. And I sometimes feel that after being on my phone too much, just like, oh my God, take this thing away from me and let me just, I don't know, tell me like a longer story or something. Can I say one thing just going back to what Jenna's criminal plot to follow this person. To follow somebody for a day, yeah, please. So have you guys ever heard of, I think it's called the Dictionary of Obscure Sorrows? It's this book that is such a good gift book, if you want to get a gift for someone or yourself. But this guy invented new words.
就像他把——这叫什么来着，当你取一个词的一部分和另一个词的一部分？他是迈克尔·斯科特吗？不是。但我们的两部剧，这也是一个相似之处。我们发明了很多词。有很多新术语。但里面有一个词的定义，他称之为，我想叫做“Sonder”（孤独自省感）。那种突然的意识到：每一个从你身边走过的人，以及
Like he took like, what's it called when you take like part of one word and part of another? Was he Michael Scott? No. But both our shows, that is another similarity. We invent a lot of words. There's a lot of new term. But there's a definition in there of a word he calls, I think it's called Sonder. And it's the feeling, the sudden realization that everyone passing you on the street and
你在高速公路上开着车时每一辆车里的每个人，这些人的内心世界都和你的一样丰富，都有着和你一样迷人的故事。我觉得有一种倾向，我们都觉得自己是主角，对吧？而其他人只是背景，或者其他人都在碍事，他们只是交通工具——但如果你真正去关注每一个车里的人，如果你真的（像珍娜打算的那样）非法跟踪他们，你会发现——你会发现像金子一样的东西，你会发现像黄金一样珍贵的东西，比如某些让人心碎的东西、某些迷人的东西、某些奇怪的新事物——但是，天哪，当你想到每个人都是多么复杂和繁复时，这几乎是难以承受的。
everyone in every car on the highway that you're driving, each of those people has just as robust and interior life as you do and just as fascinating a story as you do. And I think there's a tendency, like we all kind of, the ego main characters us, right? and everyone else's background or everyone else is like in the way they're just traffic right but like to really key into every single one of those cars if you really you know illegally followed them like Jenna's going to do like you'd find you'd find something like gold you'd find something golden like something heartbreaking something fascinating some new weird thing but yeah it's almost unbearable when you think about how complicated and complex that that every individual is
我能对我们的“办公室辣妈”观众说句话吗？各位，乔希·拉德纳给我们的这个关于“Sonder”的定义，就是当你收听《我们是如何认识你母亲的》时会获得的这种干货——我会揣摩这个想法好几天。我听你们的播客时一直都是这样，每次都是这样。你们提供了一些让我觉得“哦，我要好好消化好久”的内容。我太喜欢了。我经常在走路或开车时，看到路边某个人，然后我会想：那是我们俩的一生中，我和这个人唯一一次在同一时间出现在同一个地方，
can i just say something to our office ladies audience everyone this this definition of sonder that we have just been given from josh radner these are the types of nuggets that you're going to get when you listen to how we made your mother like i will sit with that thought for days and this happens to me all the time all the time when i listen to your podcast you you you offer something that i'm just like oh i'm just going to i'm going to digest that for so long. I freaking love that. I think all the time when I'm walking or driving, I'll think I'll see someone on the side of the road and I'll think that is the only time in both of our lifetimes that will ever be in the same place at the same time, me and that person
我不知道他们的名字。我对他们一无所知。然而在这个拥有数十亿人口的世界里，居然曾有过这样一天，我们在同一时间和地点相遇。这是多么壮丽的一件事啊？你会想：如果这家伙接下来没有发现我一整天都在尾随他，这将是我们眼神交汇的唯一瞬间。不过真的很真实。我可能会去做的，伙计们。听了这段对话我不知道了。你觉得有没有可能你先征求一下别人的同意？不行，因为那样的话就会变得不自然了。是的，没错。你知道的，那样的话，他们可能会选择比平时更健康的食物。
and I don't know their name. I don't know anything about them. And yet in this world of billions of people, there was a day when we were in the same place at the same time. And just how like magnificent is that? You're like, if this guy doesn't catch me stalking him for rest of this day. This will be the only moment our eyes make eye contact. It's so true, though. I might do it, you guys. I don't know with this conversation. Do you think there's any world where you could just ask for permission before? No, because then it might be performative. Yes, that's right. You know, then they might, they might choose healthier foods than they would.
我觉得他们拍过这个，叫做《陪审团义务》。那是电视上的一部剧集。
I think they did this and it was called jury duty. It was a series on television. which was written by two of the office writers. That's right. That's right. That's right. Brilliant show. You guys, you could just have a life pivot where you become a detective.
由《办公室》的两位编剧撰写。没错。没错。没错。精彩绝伦的剧集。伙计们，你们完全可以来个生活大转折，去当个侦探。
Well, Angela, we want to be mom detectives. Maybe this is part of why. That's a great show. Yeah. Thank you. Thank you.
好吧，安吉拉，我们想当妈妈侦探。也许这就是部分原因。那是个很棒的节目。是的。谢谢。谢谢。
We think so. We're solving crimes no one cares about. And we always have snacks. And we almost never solve it. And the snacks. At the end of every episode, our tagline is we may never know. We may never know.
我们觉得是。我们在侦破根本没人关心的案件。而且我们总是有零食。而且我们几乎从不破案。还有零食。每一集的结尾，我们的标语都是：我们可能永远不会知道。我们可能永远不会知道。
That's it. There's no payoff, Craig. Sorry. There's a lot of set up with no payoff. Believe me. Just stretch it out. We did nine years of stretching it out. Yeah. Well, I want to talk a little bit about how you guys shot the show because the office and how I met your mother, they both started around the same time. And I feel like both of our shows did a new kind of thing. Like the office did the office did the, the whole documentary style, messy camera work kind of spy shot thing. No audience. Yeah, no audience. Your show was shot in the three camera style, but was not filmed in front of an audience,
就是这样。没有回报，克雷格。抱歉。有很多铺垫却没有任何回报。相信我。就硬拖。我们拖了九年。是的。好吧，我想稍微聊聊你们拍这部剧的方式，因为《办公室》和《老爸老妈的浪漫史》大约在同一时间开播。我觉得我们的两部剧都做了一些新鲜的事情。比如《办公室》采用了纪录片风格、杂乱的镜头感以及类似偷拍的风格。没有现场观众。对，没有现场观众。你们的剧是用三机位风格拍摄的，但不是在观众面前拍摄的，
but it had a laugh track, but also you did some single camera stuff. How did it all work? Yeah, it was, we created, Carter and I, Carter is co-creator of the show with me. We really didn't know what we were doing. that's the biggest thing. We stumbled in really not knowing how to do this. We weren't like these grizzled old like sitcom hacks kind of guys. We had come from like late night television. We worked on an animated show, a couple short-lived sitcoms. We really had never written a multi-camera sitcom. So we wrote this pilot that we thought was great because it moved. It was lots of short scenes. It popped around. It played with time. And we gave it to our producer. And she was like, this is unproducible in front of an audience from the human beings. Like this is like how you, we hope you understand. that you cannot do this like friends. We're like, can't we just to keep the audience for a long time and do a lot of pre-shoots?
但它有罐头笑声，不过你们也拍了一些单机位的东西。这一切是怎么运作的？是的，我们创造了——卡特和我，卡特和我一起创作了这部剧。我们其实根本不知道自己在做什么。那是最大的一点。我们跌跌撞撞地进场，真的不知道该怎么做。我们可不是那种饱经沧桑的老情景喜剧老手。我们来自深夜电视节目。我们做过一部动画片、几部短命的情景喜剧。我们真的从来没有写过多机位情景喜剧。所以我们写了这个试播集，我们觉得它很棒，因为它很有节奏感。里面有很多短小精悍的场景。场景跳跃频繁。它玩弄了时间线。我们把它交给了我们的制片人。她的反应是：这根本无法在真人现场观众面前制作出来。就像是——我们希望你们能明白，
And they were like, you will have, it will be a hostage situation. Like the audience will just be there for three days. I'll be trying to escape. Like, it's like this, you have to break this down in a different way. And Pam Fryman and Cesar Greenberg, our brilliant director and producer who did the entire series, really came up with a way to over three days, shoot the show, kind of to look like a sitcom
你们不能像《老友记》那样拍。我们问：难道我们就不能让观众待很长时间然后拍很多预拍镜头吗？他们的回答是：那会变成一场人质事件。就像观众会在那里待三天。我会试图逃跑。就像是——你们必须用不同的方式来拆解这个。帕姆·弗莱曼和凯撒·格林伯格，我们出色的导演和制片人，他们完成了整个系列，他们真的想出了一种方法，在三天内把这部剧拍出来，拍得既有点像情景喜剧，
and kind of to look at times like a single count. We went out onto New York Street. We went on locations. We did lots of fun sort of cinematic storytelling. And we really let ourselves think about it as not just a half-hour sitcom on CBS, which, again, we were. We were, our lead-in was King of Queens when we launched, and our lead-out was two and a half men. And we were such a weird black sheep. Our numbers were not nearly as big as the show before us and the show after us, which means you're the dip.
有时又有点像单机位。我们走上纽约街头。我们去了外景。我们做了很多有趣的电影式叙事。我们真的让自己把它看作不仅仅是CBS上的半小时情景喜剧——当然，我们确实是。我们开播时的前导剧是《皇后区之王》，后接剧是《好汉两个半》。而我们是如此怪异的害群之马。我们的收视率远不如我们前后的剧集，这意味着我们是收视低谷。
You're like the hammock. You're like the, you're bringing the whole ratings of the night down. But we were always good. You know that move? We were that as well. Oh, yeah. You know that move. But we were great in 18 to 34, which CBS was looking for.
就像吊床一样。就像是，我们把当晚的整体收视率拉低了。但我们一直很棒。你知道那种操作吗？我们也是那样的。哦，对。你知道那种操作。但我们在18至34岁观众群中的表现非常棒，而这正是CBS当时正在寻找的。
They were not doing great in that younger category. And we eventually, over those first few years, started to become like their number one show in 18 to 34. And they realized, well, not as many people are watching this as watched these other shows, but more young people are watching this than watch those other shows. And that was our survival. Well, I love how it shot. even now. And I think that's one of the reasons, if I were to guess, why it, quote, unquote, holds up so well, you know? Yeah. Yeah. And I think it's why I spoke to younger viewers. In that way. Brian Eno, you know, the ambient music pioneer, Brian Eno, he has this thing about how new forms are created when the old form can't contain what the bigger expression is. So, for instance, distortion in a guitar was because the amps got blown out.
他们在年轻观众群体里的表现并不是很好。最终，在最初的几年里，我们在18到34岁观众中成为了他们收视率最高节目。他们意识到，虽然看这个节目的人没有看其他节目的人那么多，但看这个节目的年轻人比看那些节目的年轻人多。这就是我们的生存之道。我很喜欢它的镜头语言。即使到现在也是如此。我想这也是为什么它——姑且这么说吧——能如此经久不衰的原因之一，你知道吗？是的。是的。这也是为什么它能引起年轻观众的共鸣。就是那样。布赖恩·伊诺，你知道的，那个氛围音乐先驱布赖恩·伊诺，他有一个观点：当旧的形式无法容纳更宏大的表达时，新的形式就会诞生。比如说，吉他失真效果的出现，是因为音箱被轰坏了。
and then it became the sound that everyone was actually chasing. So now you have like, you're trying to mimic the sound of blowing out an amp, and that becomes a whole new genre. But it was actually a kind of mistake or something that couldn't contain it. So it's almost like Carter and Craig's naivete actually created a new form. Yeah. They kind of didn't know what we were doing. We didn't know we couldn't do it.
然后它变成了每个人都在追求的声音。所以现在你会去模仿音箱被轰坏的声音，这成了一个全新的流派。但它其实是一种错误，或者说是一种无法被原样容纳的东西。所以这就有点像卡特和克雷格的天真烂漫，实际上创造了一种新的形式。是的。他们当时有点不知道自己在做什么。我们不知道我们做不到。
Yeah. And I feel like I saw it in other things, too, after watching your show, especially like when you would have a character say something and then it would cut to a different time to the other person reacting, you know, like you would sort of set up like Ted would say something and then it would cut to Robin's reaction to Lily or things like that. And it zipped along so fun. And I feel like I've seen that in movies, but I feel like the first time I saw it really was watching your show. Yeah. Most multicameras don't move that way. I love that the office moves that way. I feel like we should say like I'm a huge fan of the office. I watched every single episode of The Office. I watch it door to doored. I'm such a huge fan. I wanted to ask all of you this question, you too, Josh, because I don't know this, the answer for you. Were you guys able to while you were on TV, while you were on the office, you come, you're shooting the office, you come home. Do you watch other sitcoms? And I'm honored, Jenna, that we were, you were watching
是的。而且我觉得在看了你们的节目之后，我在其他作品里也看到了这种风格，尤其是当你们让一个角色说一句话，然后镜头切到另一个不同时间、表现另一个人反应的时候，你知道的，就像你们会做那样的铺垫，比如泰德说了一句话，然后镜头切到罗宾或莉莉的反应，诸如此类。而且节奏非常明快有趣。我觉得我在电影里见过这种手法，但我觉得我真正第一次看到它，还是在看你们的节目的时候。是的。大多数多机位拍摄可不会那样运镜。我很喜欢《办公室》的运镜方式。我觉得我们应该表达一下——我是《办公室》的超级粉丝。我看过《办公室》的每一集。我从头到尾一集不落地看。我是超级粉丝。我想问大家这个问题，还有你，乔什，因为我不知道你的答案。你们在拍电视期间，在拍《办公室》的时候，拍完《办公室》回到家，你们还会看其他的 情景喜剧吗？我很荣幸，珍娜，你们当时在看
how I met your mother, I guess, which I never really knew that you were at that time until now. I would come home from working on how much mother all day. And the only show, the only comedy I would watch is The Office. I love The Office and my wife and I watch every episode. I could not watch any other comedies because my brain would start to compare to them. Ah, they're a bigger hit than us. Or we're better than that. I think we do this thing better than that one, but this thing we don't do as well. So I was not able to just enjoy watching comedies. I would watch like dark hour dramas and like weird movies. I could not like watch another comedy except the office. I loved and I watched in real time at the moment. But what is that for you guys? Did you guys,
《老爸老妈浪漫史》，我猜是的，我以前真不知道你那时候也在看，直到现在才知道。我每天从《老爸老妈浪漫史》的片场下班回家。我唯一会看的节目、唯一的喜剧就是《办公室》。我太喜欢《办公室》了，我和我太太看每一集。我无法看任何其他的喜剧，因为我的大脑会开始把它们作比较。啊，他们的收视率比我们高。或者我们比那个拍得好。我觉得我们某个地方比那一部拍得好，但这个地方我们没他们拍得好。所以我无法单纯地享受看喜剧的乐趣。我会去看那种黑暗压抑的剧情片和奇怪的电影。我无法看除《办公室》之外的其他喜剧。我太爱《办公室》了，而且当时是实时追看的。但对你们来说呢？你们，
Were you guys able to, like, enjoy sitcoms while you were in one? Yeah, I was. You were. I mean, oh, yeah. I watched Community. I watched Will & Grace. I watched 30 Rock, loved 30 Rock, arrested development. Yeah, I love comedy.
你们在拍情景喜剧的时候，能享受其他情景喜剧吗？是的，我可以。你可以。我是说，哦，是的。我看《废柴联盟》。我看《威尔和格蕾丝》。我看《我为喜剧狂》，非常喜欢《我为喜剧狂》，还有《发展受阻》。是的，我很喜欢喜剧。
So I was happy to come home and watch more people doing great comedy. That's great. I don't know what's wrong with me that I couldn't do it. Well, you're a creator. You're looking at it from a creator's point of view. I was I don't know why this is so I look back now and I'm like what was I doing I was still doing improv theater in the evenings I would have a show oh my god I mean I was like what am I doing those early seasons I'd be so tired because we'd get done and then I'd be like I got a nine o'clock show I better go to your comedy now we're doing the office to support your improv habit yes but yeah and then I would watch shows here and there too but I I wasn't afraid to watch them though I was enjoying it for sure. I felt like I was part of this creative community.
所以我很高兴回到家看更多人演绎精彩的喜剧。那太棒了。我不知道自己有什么毛病，为什么我就做不到。好吧，你是个创作者。你是从创作者的角度来看待它的。我当时——我不知道为什么会这样，我现在回想起来都会想：我当时在干什么？我晚上还在做即兴喜剧剧场，我当时还有演出。天哪，我的意思是，我会想：我到底在干什么？在那些早期拍摄的季节里，我会非常疲惫，因为我们拍完之后，我会想：我九点还有一场演出，我最好现在去搞点喜剧。我们当时拍《办公室》是为了支持你的即兴喜剧爱好。是的，但话虽如此，我偶尔也会看一些其他的节目，但我并不害怕看它们，我确实很享受。我觉得自己是这个创意社团的一部分。
And we would, you know, I'd watch an episode of community, the show community. And then we would have to go and be backstage with them at some NBC upfront thing. And I'd be like, look at us. It's like back in theater days when you're backstage with the different shows. And it felt, it felt smaller to me in the beginning because maybe because there wasn't streaming, maybe because we were on this tiny lot. We weren't even on a major studio. a lot, you know. Josh, I have a random tangent quickly. Yeah. How did we meet? Did we meet at one of those
我们会，你知道的，我会看一集《废柴联盟》，也就是《废柴联盟》这个节目。然后我们得去NBC的某个电视前端推介会上和他们后台相聚。我会觉得，看看我们。这就像回到了剧场时期，你和其他节目的演员们待在后台。而且我觉得它一开始给我的感觉更小一些，也许是因为当时还没有流媒体，也许是因为我们在这么个小小的外景地。我们甚至不在一个大型制片厂的片场，你知道的。乔什，我突然想扯开一个题外话。是的。我们是怎么认识的？我们是在那些
like events? Here's my memory. My memory is that one day I was invited to do a reading of your screenplay at your place. Right. And I went. Yeah. And I did it. And it was so good. And I, my memory is that that is where I met you. And I don't know if like an agent set that up or something. I, But it was the most wonderful evening. Oh, thank you. Reading with other actors, your great screenplay, and you were so nice. I feel like you played guitar for us. No, I didn't play guitar back then.
活动上认识的吗？我的记忆是这样的。我的记忆是有一天我应邀去你家参加你剧本的剧本围读。没错。然后我去了。是的。我参与了。而且那个剧本太棒了。我的记忆是，我就是在那儿认识你的。我不知道是不是经纪人安排的还是什么的。不过那是极其美妙的一个晚上。哦，谢谢你。和其他演员一起围读，读你那部精彩的剧本，而且你人超级好。我觉得你当时还给我们弹了吉他。不，我那时候不弹吉他。
That's a, that's an inserted memory. But was music playing music? Probably. I was a beautiful place. I remember that. I was like, this is so stylish. Is that where we met? My memory is I do remember you doing that reading. but I think I had met you at like an event.
那是，那是一段植入的记忆。但当时有放音乐吗？可能吧。那是个很美的地方。我记得那个。我当时想：这太有品位了。我们是在那儿认识的吗？我的记忆是——我确实记得你参与了那次围读，但我认为我是在某个活动上先见过你。
And because I had met you at the event, I think I felt comfortable, well, probably not super comfortable, but comfortable enough to either track you down or I can't remember how I got hold of you. Same. But you did end up in my living room reading my screenplay. Yes.
正因为我在活动上见过你，我想我当时觉得比较自在——好吧，可能也不是超级自在，但足够自在到去把你找出来，或者我记不清我是怎么联系上你的了。我也是。但你最后确实来到了我的客厅，读了我的剧本。是的。
Which you then went on to make. Yeah, it was happy thank you more, please, right? Yes. Yeah, yeah. I then, for years, I think we would just see each other at like the night before party, like that kind of thing, like the Emmys and the, we were just on the circuit at the same time back when those things were interesting to go to. Circuit buddies, so to speak.
而你后来还把它拍成了电影。是的，真是个开心的——谢谢你，再来一部，对吧？是的。对，对。后来好几年，我想我们都只会在那种“前夜派对”上看到彼此，类似那种场合，比如艾美奖之类的，我们俩当时正好都在那个社交圈里，就在那些活动还很有趣、值得一去的时候。可以说是“社交圈里的老熟人”吧。
But I felt like the whole, I mean, I knew Mindy a little bit before from New York, like theater days. And I knew Rain because I went to NYU to the grad acting program. And when I was there, he was directing, did you guys ever see the new Bozina, that clown show he directed? No, but I wish I had. It was genius. like so incredible. And he directed that.
但我感觉整个——我是说，我以前在纽约就稍微认识一点明迪，比如在剧场时期的时候。而且我认识雷恩，因为我曾去纽约大学的表演研究生项目就读。我还在那儿的时候，他在导演一出戏，你们看过他导演的那部叫《新博齐纳》的小丑秀吗？没有，但我希望我看过。那简直是天才之作。太不可思议了。而且那是他导演的。
So he was always at NYU when I was there. So I knew him. But I always felt connected to your guy's show because one, we were on the air at the same time and going through some of the strange life-altering weird vertigo that anyone goes through. But also I felt like you guys had like theater roots. Like there were a lot of like theater actors in your show.
所以我在纽约大学的时候他总在那儿。所以我认识他。但我一直觉得我和你们的节目有一种特殊的联系，因为第一，我们当时在同一时期播出，并且都在经历那种改变人生的、奇怪的、让人头晕目眩的体验——任何经历过的人都会有这种感觉。但同时我也觉得你们有戏剧的根基。比如你们的节目里有很多戏剧演员。
You know, there was a... And even when I was watching customer survey, like I was like, this is like such like old. timey, like the, um, the, the, the fake call between Michael and Dwight and the buttlicker scene. William Butlicker. Yeah. It's so good. That is like, that might as well be like Shakespearean clowns or like Hamadia del Arte. Like it's such like classic. And then they start taking it very serious. The stakes get really high and there's literally zero stakes. Like a million. It just struck me. Like so old timey, three stooge like Shakespeare clown. Like, like, old,
你知道的，有一个……甚至当我看《顾客调查》那一集的时候，我在想：这太有老派的风格了，比如，迈克尔和德怀特之间那个虚假的电话，还有拍马屁精的场景。威廉·巴特利克（拍马屁精）。是的。太棒了。那感觉就像莎士比亚戏剧里的滑稽小丑，或者像意大利即兴喜剧。太经典了。然后他们开始变得非常严肃。赌注变得非常高，而实际上赌注完全为零。就像有一百万。这突然击中了我。太老派了，有点像滑稽三杰，又有点像莎士比亚喜剧里的小丑，就像，像那种古老的，
just in and we do that like some of the Barney Ted stuff could get like that you know in our show and I always love that feeling that you're connected to like actors from the like 16th century or something like like this is an ancient art you know I always love that feeling yes that's how we met that's how we met it's so funny to me though that you mentioned that Barney and Ted could be sort of like Jim and Dwight in that scene yeah because I don't know if you've seen this online but there are there's a whole article that says the office characters and they're how I met your mother counterparts. Oh my God. Wow. That's amazing. And they do say Barney is Dwight and that that Ted is Jim. Yeah. You know, it was so funny. When I was watching the episode, the looks, Jenna, that
就——而且我们也会那样做，比如巴尼和泰德的一些桥段在我们的节目里有时也会变成那样，你知道的。我一直很喜欢那种感觉：你觉得你和16世纪的演员们有着某种联系，就像，这是一门古老的艺术，你知道的。我一直很喜欢这种感觉。是的，我们就是这样认识的。我们就是这样认识的。不过在我看来，你提到巴尼和泰德在某种程度上可以像那一幕里的吉姆和德怀特，这真的太有趣了，因为——是的，因为我不知道你在网上看过没有，有一整篇文章都在盘点《办公室》的角色以及他们在《老爸老妈浪漫史》里对应的角色。哦，天哪。哇。太神奇了。他们确实说巴尼就是德怀特，而泰德就是吉姆。是的。你知道的，太逗了。当我看到那一集的时候，珍娜，你和
you and John get to give to the camera were like looks that Ted would have given to the camera were the camera there. You know what I'm saying? Yes. Ted was allowed. Yeah, yeah. If Ted was allowed that convention, he would constantly be looking at the camera like Jim and Pam, you know? Yeah. He just, it was like the camera wasn't there. Although we have this theory, we're working on a theory that Barney was the only character who knew he was in a sitcom. Yeah.
约翰投给镜头的那些眼神，就好像如果摄像机在场的话，泰德也会投给镜头的眼神。你知道我在说什么吗？是的。泰德是被允许这么做的。是的，是的。如果泰德被允许有这种表现手法，他也会像吉姆和帕姆那样不断地看着镜头，你知道吗？是的。他只是，这感觉就像摄像机根本不在场。不过我们有一个理论，我们正在研究一个理论：巴尼是唯一一个知道自己身处情景喜剧中的角色。是的。
Because the way Neil walks into a room, sometimes it's like he's expecting entrance applause. Yeah. Yeah. That's true. Well, it's, Barney and Dwight are so similar because they are so deeply living in their own delusional narrative. They have created and curated their own words. that they're just utterly inhabiting and like they intersect with other people but they're the
因为尼尔走进一个房间的方式，有时就像他期待着开场掌声一样。是的。是的。这倒也是。不过，巴尼和德怀特非常相似，因为他们都深深地活在自己妄想出来的叙事中。他们创造并精心打造了自己的世界，
main character in this whole other world that it's not the real world and it's that's why there's such fun characters to write and why the Neil and Rain were so amazing because they just committed so a billion percent to those characters realities they're just in a different movie than everybody else and they have their own code of ethics and rules that they honor like they live by them yes This is what the internet says about them. Are you ready? Yeah. It says this, both characters are defined by their over-the-top personalities, rigid adherence to their own elaborate rulebooks, and pursuit of power and success, though, with vastly different moral codes.
他们完全沉浸在其中，并与其他人产生交集，但他们才是这个完全脱离现实的整个世界里的主角，正因如此，他们才是写起来非常有趣的角色，也正因如此，尼尔和雷恩才那么惊艳，因为他们百分之百地投入到了那些角色的现实中。他们只是生活在和所有人不同的另一部电影里，他们有着自己奉行的道德准则和规则——他们是按那些规则生活的。是的。这就是互联网上对他们的评价。准备好了吗？是的。上面是这么说的：这两个角色的共同特点是夸张的个性、对自创的繁复规则手册的严格遵守，以及对权力和成功的追求，尽管他们的道德准则大相径庭。
Yeah. It's eerie how many. I think there are so many similarities between these two shows. Because, like, we had a couple on the show that was a really lovely, cute couple that was still funny when they were together as a couple. They didn't need to be fighting all the time. They were funny as a couple. You enjoyed watching them. They didn't need a problem every week.
是的。这两部剧有多少相似之处，简直令人毛骨悚然。因为，比如，我们的剧里有一对情侣，他们非常可爱、讨人喜欢，而且当他们作为情侣在一起时依然很有趣。他们不需要整天吵架。他们作为情侣本身就很有趣。看着他们就是一种享受。他们不需要每周都遇到什么问题。
They didn't need an argument every week. In fact, fans would get upset when there would be trouble between these two characters, which I know Jim and Pam, it was like, people did not want to see too much go wrong between Jim and Pam. And Marshall and Lily on our show, Jason and Allison, like, they were a beloved couple. Like, when we were all in, I really do feel like we all went to TV college at the same time because we were like, and I felt a very deep connection to your show because it really was almost the only. at Com. I could watch. I don't know why, again, what's wrong with me? She talked to my therapist about this later. But you guys, like, I felt such a connection to Jim
他们不需要每周都吵架。事实上，当这两位角色之间出现矛盾时，粉丝们会感到沮丧，我知道吉姆和帕姆也是这样，人们不想看到吉姆和帕姆之间出太多差错。还有我们剧里的马歇尔和莉莉，杰森和艾利森，他们是一对备受喜爱的伴侣。就像，当我们全情投入时，我真的觉得我们就像是一起去上了电视大学，因为我们当时感觉——而且我对你们的节目有着非常深厚的感情，因为它真的几乎是唯一一部我能看的情景喜剧。我不知道为什么，再次说明，我有什么毛病？她以后可以跟我的心理医生谈谈这个。但你们，就像我对吉姆和帕姆有着深深的共鸣，
and Pam, because Marshall and Lily on the show are based on my wife and I. Like, we went to college. We met, I was 18. She was like 16 and a half because she had skipped here in high school. And we were these kids. That and a half is really important. I know. Yeah, it is. We were babies. And we became like, we were the old married couple by our mid-20s. We were like, grandparents compared to all of these single people out there. And so Marshall and Lily are like so close to my heart. So I think part of the reason I could watch The Office and just love it was I loved Jim and Pam so much. It was such a like I loved their connection so much. And it's really hard to write a happy couple that gets along and make it funny. I think you guys really, really did that.
因为剧中的马歇尔和莉莉是以我和我太太为原型的。我们上大学时认识的，我18岁。她大概16岁半，因为她在高中跳过级。我们当时还是些孩子。那个“半”岁非常重要。我知道。是的，确实重要。我们当时还是小不点。然后在我们二十岁出头的时候，我们就成了那种老夫老妻。比起外面那些单身的人，我们就像是爷爷奶奶辈的。所以马歇尔和莉莉深深触动了我的心。因此我想我能看《办公室》并深深喜爱它的部分原因，是因为我太喜欢吉姆和帕姆了。那种感觉就像——我太喜欢他们之间的联系了。要写出一对相处融洽又快乐、同时还能保持趣味的情侣是非常困难的。我觉得你们真的、真的做到了这一点。
And then there's this whole thing where Dwight is kind of Barney. There's a lot of Jim and Ted overlaps. Like it really, it struck me watching this episode of The Office. How many similarities And similarities in tone, too, where things start off as little jokes. And then by the end of the episode, there's this stealthy switcheroo where there's like a great dramatic twist that comes out of some little seed that's been planted. The little Bluetooth earpieces are a fun little bit and a fun running gimmick. And at the end, they create this huge dramatic moment. That is so true.
然后还有整个德怀特有点像巴尼的设定。吉姆和泰德之间也有很多重合之处。看《办公室》这一集的时候，真的让我感触颇深。有多少相似之处啊。基调上的相似之处也很明显，事情往往以小笑话开场。然后到了剧集快结束时，会有一次巧妙的乾坤大挪移，某个微小的伏笔最终变成了一个精彩的戏剧性反转。那些小巧的蓝牙耳机是一个有趣的小包袱，也是一个贯穿始终的搞笑噱头。而到了最后，它们创造出了一个巨大的戏剧高潮。这太真实了。
I love that. So I have a question, Josh, if you were in the scene and you had an idea for a line, like, were you able to just say to the writer on set or Craig or someone, um, hey, can I try this alt? Or what if I spin it this way? Was that, did you have that sort of collaboration? Yes, for sure. Like, I mean, one of the, I think we talked about this, Craig,
我太喜欢了。所以我有个问题，乔什，如果你在片场拍戏时对某句台词有个点子，比如，你能不能直接对现场的编剧、克雷格或者其他人说：“嘿，我能试试这个备选台词吗？”或者“如果我这么发挥会怎么样？”你有过这种合作空间吗？是的，肯定的。比如，我觉得我们讨论过这个，克雷格，
but one of the only ones that I'm sure made it on the air was I had to drop off a letter that I then regretted putting in the mailbox. And I climbed into the mailbox and then got stuck in the mailbox. Was that? I remember this episode, yeah. And, but I asked either Craig or Carter, whoever was on set, I said, because nailed it was a catchphrase. So I said, can I just drop it in the mail and say,
但能确定最终播出的其中一个桥段是：我得去投递一封信，而我后来又后悔把信塞进邮箱了。于是我爬进了邮箱里，结果卡在邮箱里了。是那个吗？我记得这一集，是的。但是，我问了克雷格或者卡特——当时在现场的任何人，我说——因为“绝了（nailed it）”是一个流行语，所以我说：我能不能直接把它丢进信箱然后说：
mailed it instead of nailed it, right? And that ended up, I think that ended up in the episode. Yeah, that was in. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But most of the time, I knew how tightly scripted the things were. There wasn't, it was like a Jenga, you know, it was like the moment you fattened up something, it would be like, it was so dependent upon the rhythm and the quickness of the thing that it never felt like,
“寄了（mailed it）”而不是“绝了（nailed it）”，对吧？然后这个点子，我想最后确实剪进剧集里了。是的，用了。对，对，对。但大多数时候，我知道剧本的台词写得有多严丝合缝。没有多少即兴发挥的空间，它就像叠层木块（Jenga）游戏一样，你知道的，一旦你给某个地方添油加醋，就会破坏平衡。整个情节太依赖于节奏和反应的敏捷度了，所以从来不会让人觉得：
we have all the time in the world, you know? Yeah. Because the shooting of it was always, the schedule was always very tight, as it always is. Yeah. But we didn't have those kind of breaths that you guys had. It was a different pace show. Yeah, and you wanted to leave room for those emotional moments at the end, like the end of this episode, it has some moments where clearly room was left.
我们有的是时间，你知道的。因为拍摄过程一直都是这样，档期总是非常紧凑，就像往常一样。是的。但我们没有你们那种可以喘息的空间。这是一部节奏不同的剧。是的，而且你们想为结尾的情感时刻留出空间，比如这一集的结尾，它包含了一些显然留有余地的时刻。
Like, Angela, just to get to, I love the scene with you and Dwight at the end and everything that's going on between the two of you as that farm is booked is where the wedding going to be, there's two great, like, ticking clock, like a little ticking time bombs that are started at the end of this episode, too little, what's going to happen with Jim and Pam, this guy's clearly flirting with her, or at least there's this enticement, is she going to move to, is she going to stay in New York, right? And then there's this other, and I really didn't see it coming. I forgot this happened. The Dwight Angela stuff is this other like, pip, and a little ticking time bomb has been said, like a little fuse has been lit. And it's two of them at the
比如，安吉拉，说到最后你和德怀特的对手戏，以及随着那个农场被预定为婚礼举办地，你们俩之间正在发生的一切，有两个绝佳的、类似倒计时定时炸弹的元素在这一集的结尾被点燃了：两个微小的、关于吉姆和帕姆会发生什么的悬念——这家伙显然在调情，或者至少存在着某种诱惑，她是要搬去纽约，还是留在纽约，对吧？然后还有另一个悬念，我真的没料到。我忘了这事儿发生了。德怀特和安吉拉的剧情是另一个类似“嘀嗒”作响的定时炸弹，导火索已经被点燃了。而且是在这一集的
very end of the episode that carry you into the next episode. We tried to do that as often as we cut on how I met your mother just because you had to wait a week, right? People weren't binging these shows. You had people tune in one week from tonight for the exciting next part of the story. What was that scene with the two of you was amazing? You and Rain in that scene, just making the deepest eye contact of all time. What was that? What was that scene like to shoot? But it's very intense. It was great. Very intense. A lot with a lot with just a look on our show. And so much of our show was reacting, you know, and that definitely for the supporting cast. you would have cast members that were making a lot of the action and the big moments happen.
最末尾，由他们两个人的戏份把观众带入了下一集。我们在《老爸老妈浪漫史》里也尽量经常这样做，因为你必须等上一周，对吧？人们当时可不是在刷剧。你会吸引观众在从今晚起一周后收看故事激动人心的下一部分。你们俩的那场戏太棒了！你和雷恩在那场戏里，进行了有史以来最深情的眼神交流。那是什么样的？那种戏拍起来是什么感觉？但那非常激烈。太棒了。非常激烈。在我们的剧里，很多时候只需要一个眼神就足够了。而且我们的剧有很大一部分是靠反应，你知道的，尤其是对于配角而言。你们剧组会有一些演员来推动剧情和高潮时刻的发生。
And then the rest of us were reacting to it. And for that love triangle with Dwight and Andy, it was so delicious. I loved every single second of it. I was like, give me more. What else? What else can I be a part of here? And that was really fun for a supporting cast when they got to be sort of in the main story. But I loved it.
然后我们剩下的所有人都在做出反应。对于德怀特和安吉拉以及安迪之间的那个三角恋，那种感觉太美妙了。我喜欢里面的每一秒钟。我当时心想：再多给我点！还有什么？我还可以在这里参与什么？对于配角来说，当他们能稍微参与到主线故事中时，这真的非常有趣。但我太喜欢了。
Angela always loved Dwight. That's how I played it. You know, we talk, and Josh, and I'm sure you have this process too, but Jen and I both had our own story for our character that was part of our truth in whatever moment. So if Angela isn't always just a bitch, there's many layers to her. And so my truth was I always loved him. Yeah. And he put my cat in a freezer, and it took me a long time to get over that. and poor Andy was just sort of in the middle, you know?
安吉拉一直都爱着德怀特。我是这么来演绎这个角色的。我们常说——乔什，我确信你也有这样的创作过程——但珍娜和我都有各自为角色设定的故事线，这是我们在任何特定时刻内心真实情感的一部分。所以，如果安吉拉不总是表现得像个刻薄鬼，她身上其实有很多层次。所以我的真实想法是：我一直都爱着他。是的。而他把我的猫放进了冷冻库，我花了很长时间才走出来。而可怜的安迪当时只是夹在中间，你知道的。
Yeah. But I loved those scenes. Can I tell you my two favorite things from that final scene that I just love so much? Okay, so the first one is I love how it shot. I love how the camera is singles on Angela and Dwight and there's all the eye contact. But then very slowly you see Andy Creighton to Angelus. single. I don't.
是的。但我太喜欢那些场景了。我能告诉你我最喜欢的最后那一幕里的两个细节吗？我真的太喜欢了。好吧，第一个我喜欢的是它的镜头运用。我喜欢镜头如何给安吉拉和德怀特特写，并且有那么多的眼神交流。但随后非常缓慢地，你会看到安迪慢慢地挪进安吉拉的镜头里。我不知道。
Because he's, and it's just like, it makes me laugh every time. And the other thing is, I love how when Dwight is showing them the book of like what can happen when they get married at Shrewd farms, there's a photo of a couple being married while standing in their own graves. And that is a callback to like some talking head that Dwight had about how Shrewts always get married standing in their own graves. Oh, my God. So this just photograph is just a quick callback to that.
因为他在——这每次都让我笑喷。另一件事是，我喜欢当德怀特向他们展示那本关于在施鲁特农场结婚会有什么后果的书时，里面有一张照片，是一对新人站在他们自己的坟墓里举行婚礼。这呼应了德怀特之前的一个“面对镜头独白”，他说过施鲁特家族的人结婚时总是站在自己的坟墓里。哦，天哪！所以这张照片只是对那一点的一个小小的快速呼应。
But then in the finale episode of the office, Angela and Dwight get married at Shrewd Farms standing in their own graves. That's amazing. And I just love the symmetry of that, of the one, two, three. You had to wait nine years for that to pay off, but it does. I felt like our writers were so good at that. We're in this incredibly small group of people who can say we got to do that. You got to do one thing in one year, another thing to keep it alive three years later or whatever.
但到了《办公室》的大结局那一集，安吉拉和德怀特真的在施鲁特农场站在他们自己的坟墓里结婚了。太神奇了。我太喜欢这种从一到二再到三的对称感了。你必须等上九年才能看到这个伏笔兑现，但它确实兑现了。我觉得我们的编剧在这方面太厉害了。我们属于一个极其特殊的极小群体，可以自豪地说我们做到了这一点。你一年里做了一件事，三年后又做了一件事让它延续下去，诸如此类。
And then four years later, how many years later, you get to pay it off in this completely different way. You guys did that all the time. We got to do that. We really got to do that. And we did keep track of that. We had a running list of things we had to pay off like that. There's another one in this episode, too. It's Kelly at the very beginning says, Michael's telling everyone he's engaged to Holly.
然后四年后，不管是多少年后，你用一种完全不同的方式让它得到了兑现。你们总是这样做。我们确实做到了。我们真的做到了。而且我们确实一直在追踪这些。我们有一个正在进行的清单，记录着我们必须这样兑现的伏笔。这一集里其实还有另一个。凯莉在最开始的时候说，迈克尔正在告诉所有人他跟霍莉订婚了。
And she's like, I got my dress. I hope it's okay. It's white. Which is she wears a white dress to Phyllis's wedding. You know, so it's like all the ways that our writers kept track of that. Kelly has been waiting to wear white to somebody's wedding to steal their thunder. Well, it's a good thing, you know, they say in the theater, like, if there's a gun, if you see a gun in the first act, it has to go off in the third act, right?
然后她说：“我连裙子都准备好了。希望没问题。是白色的。”也就是她穿着一件白色的裙子去参加菲莉丝的婚礼。你知道的，所以这就体现在我们编剧追踪这些细节的各种方式上。凯莉一直等着在某人的婚礼上穿白色衣服来抢风头。好吧，这倒是个好习惯，你知道的，他们在戏剧界常说：如果在第一幕里出现了一把枪，那么在第三幕里它就必须开火，对吧？
But this is like, if you see something in the third season, it has to go off in the ninth season. Like, this is like really playing the long game. And I love that I didn't have to be the storehouse of wisdom of like, I, I love that there were a team of writers that were keeping track of that stuff because I would have lost track of all that. I loved your whole slap runner, you know? It's like, I just love that. That's one of those things, Josh, that we can't do in real life, right?
但这就像是：如果在第三季里你看到了某个东西，它就必须在第九季里开火。这就像是在下一盘真正的大棋。我很庆幸自己不需要成为智慧的仓库，去记住所有这些——我很庆幸有一个编剧团队在追踪这些东西，因为我自己早就忘光了。我很喜欢你们那个“扇耳光”的贯穿包袱，你知道的？我就很喜欢那个。乔什，那是我们在现实生活中做不到的事情之一，对吧？
We can't have the slap bet and get to use the slaps whenever we want them. And just like all the times that, like, Jim and Dwight slapped each other, just those ridiculous moments. That are so fun. The slap bet was from real life. Carter and his high school, it was high, the keyword high school. Carter and one of his friends in high school had a long-running series of slap-bats going and would just slap the crap out of each other to pay them off. But I think you have to be in high school for that to work.
我们不能搞一个“耳光赌局”，然后想什么时候扇耳光就什么时候扇。就像吉姆和德怀特互扇耳光的所有那些时刻，简直太荒谬了。那些真的太搞笑了。“耳光赌局”来源于现实生活。卡特和他的高中同学——关键词是“高中”。卡特和他的一个高中同学进行了一场旷日持久的“耳光赌局”系列赛，为了兑现承诺，他们会毫不留情地互扇耳光。但我觉得你得在读高中时这么干才行。
I think that ends at graduation. Before we finish, I just want to say besides the guacamole line, which is an all-timer, Dwight saying to Kelly, you juk the stats cupcake is also one of my favorite. That's an unbelievable good line. That was what I wrote down. He did the stats cupcake. Well, guys, thank you for joining us. our podcast and our network. Thank you.
我觉得这种事一毕业就结束了。在我们结束之前，我只想说，除了那个堪称史上最佳的“鳄梨酱”台词之外，德怀特对凯莉说的那句“你篡改了数据，纸杯蛋糕”，也是我最喜欢的台词之一。那是句好得不可思议的台词。那正是我记下来的台词。你篡改了数据，纸杯蛋糕。好吧，伙计们，谢谢你们加入我们的播客和我们的网络。谢谢。
Yes. Thank you. So great to be with you guys today and in general. Thank you for having us on the team. Well, we are so thrilled and we know Office Ladies is just going to love, love your show. You're doing such a fantastic job. We feel honored to have you be part of our network. Thank you guys.
是的。谢谢。今天能和你们在一起真是太棒了，总而言之，谢谢你们邀请我们加入这个团队。好吧，我们非常激动，而且我们知道《办公室淑女》一定会非常、非常喜欢你们的节目。你们做得太棒了。能让你们成为我们网络的一部分，我们感到非常荣幸。谢谢你们，伙计们。
Oh, thanks. Yeah. This is just, I don't know if people, you know, know how this started, but I just called Jenna to talk about rewatch podcasts and to see if maybe she wanted to hop on our show as a guest and talk about the weirdness of playing one character for a decade and all this stuff. And then she said, who's producing you guys? And I said, well, Craig and I are basically doing that, you know, we're doing this with a small team on our own. And she said, well, Angela and I are kind of expanding our empire. And we'd love to, uh, did I say, you didn't say empire. Did you say empire? I like it. She was twisting a fake mustache. And she said,
哦，谢谢。是的。这真的是——我不知道大家知不知道这一切是怎么开始的，但我当时只是给珍娜打电话，聊了聊重看播客的事，看看她是否愿意作为嘉宾上我们的节目，聊聊扮演一个角色长达十年之久的奇妙感受以及诸如此类的事情。然后她说：“是谁在给你们制作节目？”我说：“嗯，基本上我和克雷格在搞这个，你知道的，我们带着一个小团队自己在做。”然后她说：“嗯，安吉拉和我在扩展我们的帝国。我们很想——”我是说，你当时说了“帝国”吗？你说了“帝国”吗？我喜欢这个。她当时正转动着一根假胡子，然后她说：
We're trying to... As she was following you. I was like, I turned around. I was like, where was just right there? I was like, oh, Josh, I know. I know what you put up to. You and Craig Thomas. I've been following you both as you're going through his trash.
“我们正试图……”当时她正学着你的样子。我当时转过身去心想：刚才不还在那儿吗？我当时想：“哦，乔什，我知道。我知道你在搞什么鬼。你和克雷格·托马斯。我一直在暗中观察你们翻垃圾桶。”
Well, it was really like, it was such a... It was just one of those things that, like, oh, yeah, that makes all this sense in the world. And then I think you guys listened to an episode or two. And then there was a much more formal invitation to join you guys. And it wasn't like, we didn't have to deliberate. It was like, oh, no, no, no, these are exactly who we want to be aligned with. And we just love what you guys have been up to. And we're just thrilled to be working alongside you.
嗯，这真的就像——这就像是那种“哦，对啊，这在情理之中”的事情。然后我想你们听了一两集节目。接着就发出了正式得多的邀请，邀请我们加入你们。而且我们甚至不需要深思熟虑，就觉得：“哦，不，不，不，这正是我们想要结盟的人。”我们太喜欢你们一直在做的事了，能和你们并肩作战，我们感到无比激动。
So thank you so much. One last thing before we go, Craig, we want to give a plug for your book. It's called That's Not How It Happened. You gave us advanced copies. We're both reading it and loving it. It's a beautiful book. Do you want to tell us about it? Yeah, thank you.
所以非常感谢。在我们离开前还有最后一件事，克雷格，我们想为你的书做个宣传。书名叫《事情不是那样的》（That's Not How It Happened）。你送了我们预读本，我们俩都在读，而且爱不释手。这是一本非常美的书。你想跟我们聊聊它吗？好的，谢谢。
Yeah, it's inspired in part by my own family and by my journey raising my son, who has a rare genetic syndrome where he has some learning disabilities and some health challenges. And some of that material combined with some of my years of working and writing in Hollywood, and both of those elements are in this book. It is a book, the sort of a quickie plot line is the mom and a family, kind of like my own, and it's told from four perspectives, a mom, a dad, and two kids. I love that.
是的，它的灵感部分来源于我自己的家庭，以及我抚养我儿子的经历。我儿子患有一种罕见的综合征，这导致他在学习上有一定障碍，健康上也面临一些挑战。其中一些素材，结合我在好莱坞工作和写作多年的经历，这两部分元素都融入了这本书中。简单来说，这本书的快速情节线是：一个家庭里的母亲，有点像我自己的家庭，故事是从四个视角讲述的——妈妈、爸爸和两个孩子。我太喜欢这个设定了。
Yeah, it's very perspective-shifty, which is sort of similar to both of our shows in various ways, right? There's some office and hymium in here. But yeah, the mom has written a memoir about raising her son who has Down syndrome in the book, who is now a young adult facing that huge question of what does an adult life look like for a young adult with a disability who's getting outside of school and what's next? And a lot of parents like me call that the cliff. School ends and then what happens after the cliff. And this is sort of the novels about that. And the novel, the mom has written a memoir about raising her son to this point, and Hollywood comes a knock in to make a movie out of the memoir. And in the process of trying to get this movie made of their lives,
是的，它的视角经常转换，这在某种程度上和我们两部剧在不同方面的风格有点像，对吧？里面既有《办公室》的影子，也有《老爸老妈浪漫史》的影子。但话说回来，书中的妈妈写了一本关于抚养患有唐氏综合征的儿子的回忆录，而现在这个儿子已经长大成人，面临着一个巨大的问题：一个有残疾的年轻人，在即将告别学校之后，成年生活会是什么样？接下来该怎么办？像我这样的许多家长把这叫做“悬崖”。学校生活结束了，然后悬崖之后会发生什么？这部小说大致就是关于这个的。在小说中，妈妈写了一本关于把儿子抚养到这个阶段的回忆录，好莱坞找上门来，想把这本回忆录拍成电影。在这个试图把他们的人生搬上银幕的过程中，
it raises all kinds of questions about whose story is this? How do we all see our lives? How do four members of a family tell their own story? It's funny. It fits into a lot of what we've been talking about on this episode, right? Everyone's in their own story. Everyone's the main character in their own story. The book is called That's Not How It Happened because you're constantly switching in and out of these four perspectives into these character's shoes and out of them to hear what they think the story is and how the next person that's going to speak sees it completely differently. And so it's a comedy. It's a dromedy, I guess you would call it.
它引发了各种各样的问题：这究竟是谁的故事？我们是如何看待各自人生的？一个家庭的四个成员是如何讲述他们自己的故事的？这很有趣。它契合了我们在这一集里一直在讨论的许多内容，对吧？每个人都在自己的故事里。每个人都是自己故事里的主角。这本书之所以叫《事情不是那样的》，是因为你不断地在四个视角之间切换，走进这些角色的内心，又跳出来，去听听他们认为故事到底是怎样的，以及下一个要发言的人是如何以完全不同的方式看待这一切的。所以它是一部喜剧，一部“悲喜剧”（dromedy），我想你可以这么称呼它。
And it's my favorite thing I've ever written besides how I met your mother. And it means so much to me that you guys are reading it and would support it. So thank you. Yes, yes. You guys, get a copy. That's not how it happened. I'm going to put a link in our stories. It's out now.
这是除了《老爸老妈浪漫史》之外我写过最喜欢的作品。你们在读它并且愿意支持它，这对我的意义太重大了。所以谢谢你们。是的，是的。各位，去买一本吧。《事情不是那样的》。我会在我们的社交动态里放一个链接。现在已经上市了。
Can confirm that it's an incredible. An incredibly fun, wonderful read. You know, when your dear friend hands you and says, hey, will you read my novel, there's always a little nervousness. Like, uh-oh. I hope I like it. This is too long to be bad. This is going to be really bad.
我可以证实，这是一本不可思议的书。是一本极其有趣、美妙的读物。你知道的，当你的挚友把书递给你并说：“嘿，你能读读我的小说吗？”心里总会有那么一点紧张。心想：噢哦。希望我喜欢它。这么长的一定很烂。这肯定会超级烂。
I was just delighted by every page of this book. I think it's such a wonderful story. It's so moving, so funny. There's not a dull moment. It's just a page turner, tearjerker. It's fantastic. It means the world to me coming from you guys. So much hard. Also, I should say, I'm bringing a lead here. Josh Radner and Kobe Smolders are read the two parent roles in the audiobook.
但我被这本书的每一页都深深惊艳了。我觉得这是一个如此美妙的故事。如此感人，又如此好笑。没有一处令人乏味。这是一本让人爱不释手、催人泪下的书。太棒了。从你们口中听到这些评价，对我而言意义重大。太感人了。另外我得说，我这里有个重磅消息。乔什·拉德纳和科比·史莫德斯在有声书里给那两个父母的角色配了音。
The four perspectives are two parents and then two kids. That's fantastic. So how I met your mother fans, please know there is a little hymnium love in the audio book of this novel. Oh, I love that. Well, we'll definitely share all of this with our audience. We are just so thrilled Josh and Craig to have you on the Office Ladies Network. You guys go listen to how we made your mother podcast right now streaming wherever you get your podcasts. Well, I loved that. So did I. Also, I loved the super fan of customer survey.
这四个视角是两位父母和两个孩子。太棒了！所以《老爸老妈浪漫史》的粉丝们，请注意，这部小说的有声书里有一点点“老爸老妈浪漫史”的爱意。哦，我太喜欢了！好的，我们一定会把这一切分享给我们的听众。乔什和克雷格，能让你们加入“办公室淑女网络”，我们真的感到非常激动。各位，现在就去收听《老爸老妈浪漫史》播客吧，各大播客平台均可同步收听。好吧，我太喜欢了。我也是。另外，我还很喜欢关于《顾客调查》的超级粉丝内容。
And lady, I feel like since we didn't get to talk about some of the new stuff that we discovered, I want to do a full breakdown of that episode. And we'll share all of our tidbits. Yeah, I'd like that too. I mean, you and I really dug into it. And then we were so excited to talk to with Josh and Craig. We didn't really get into it as much as. I think we thought we were going to.
而且，女士们，我觉得既然我们没有时间聊聊我们发现的一些新内容，我想对那一集做一个全面的剖析。我们会分享我们所有的趣闻轶事。是的，我也这么想。我是说，你和我真的深入探讨了它。然后我们太兴奋于和乔什、克雷格聊天了，以至于我们没有像原本以为的那样深入讨论它。
Well, let's do it, and then we'll put it out next week. So it'll be like a really nice companion for today's episode. Oh, I like that. And everyone, be sure and check out our interview on How We Made Your Mother is dropping as a bonus episode on the How We Made Your Mother feed tomorrow. Yeah. Go there now and click subscribe so you don't miss it. It's really fun.
好吧，我们就这么办，然后我们在下周把它发布出来。所以它会像是今天这一集的绝佳伴侣篇。哦，我喜欢这样！各位，一定要去看看我们在《老爸老妈浪漫史》播客上的采访，它将作为一期特别彩蛋节目于明天在《老爸老妈浪漫史》的订阅源上线。是的。现在就去那里点击订阅，这样就不会错过了。真的非常有趣。
We watched their pilot episode, and then we chat all about it. Yeah. All right, you guys, have a great day. Don't be a butt licker. We'll see. in next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela
我们观看了他们的试播集，然后畅聊了关于它的一切。是的。好了，各位，祝你们过美好的一天。别当“拍马屁精”。我们下周见。感谢收听《办公室淑女》。《办公室淑女》是Audyssey呈献的节目，由珍娜·费舍和安吉拉
Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. I don't know. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
金西制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。Audyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。本期节目由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带后期制作。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿创作的《鲁珀特树》。不知道。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。